paradoxes can be mind-bending they can
be frustrating or they can be enjoyable
puzzles to solve
whether they come from the realm of time
travel or everyday life paradoxes can
spur some of our deepest thinking and
most perplexing views of the world
around us
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives several
experts cover paradoxes that will make
your brain spin
we begin now with one paradox that will
change your perception of decision
making for good
enjoy
having no choices can be a terrible
experience and research shows that
societal limitations on choice reduce
happiness for everyone in that society
more liberal countries with more options
for their citizens produce greater
quality of life
so too little choice is a terrible thing
but the paradox of choice is that too
much choice is equally terrible because
it becomes paralyzing
think of how much time and energy you
spend on simple basic decisions type of
toothpaste type of milk type of yogurt
and then consider that with our
abundance of choices you have to do that
every day
all day long on a million choices
ranging from the small and insignificant
to the major and life-changing
the problem with having so many choices
is that every decision requires effort
we feel like we're more likely to make
mistakes and we feel the psychological
consequences of our mistakes more
severely when we're unhappy we blame
ourselves we think we made the wrong
choice
so no wonder we're all so exhausted our
environment requires constant cognitive
effort just to make it through the day
and then we blame ourselves whenever we
get it wrong
the stress over what we think we did
wrong can be powerful even when we've
done something very good
one analysis of olympians found that
gold medalists and bronze medalists look
happy standing up there on the winner's
podium most gold and bronze medalists
are smiling but what about silver
medalists they have the agony of coming
close
43 of silver medalists had expressions
that looked sad
14 looked angry and contemptuous
29 were stone-faced expressionless
they were missing the thrill of what
they've achieved they got a silver medal
at the olympics but it's in the regret
of what they missed they didn't get the
gold
so it's a great reminder to think about
the places in our own lives where we're
so focused on what we don't have that we
miss all the great stuff we do have
some researchers have suggested that one
way to make sense of the demands on our
time and money is to focus on
experiences over stuff
we get more happiness when we spend our
money on things we do
rather than things we own
think about a vacation there's pleasure
in planning it pleasure in going on it
and then pleasure in sharing the photos
and telling the stories of it
long after a similarly priced item would
just be gathering dust somewhere
things that create experience musical
instruments craft supplies can also lead
to the happiness of experience but only
if you actually use them so a guitar you
play boosts happiness over the long haul
the satisfaction of learning how to play
the connection of playing with friends
but a fancy collection of guitars
hanging on the wall just becomes another
dust collection
so let's talk about strategies you can
use to reduce the stress of an
overabundance of choice
using these strategies to lessen the
stressors of choice based on our
environment of abundance may help you to
more effectively manage your energy
for instance you can actually place
constraints on your own freedom of
choice these can be simple pick the one
type of milk one type of toothpaste one
type of yogurt you will always buy then
you don't have to waste energy making
that same decision over and over again
if you shop online pick a few stores and
stick with them if you fly pick one or
two airlines that have good prices and
serve your local airport the benefit is
you're spending less time looking at
options and when you get rewards like
airline miles you're consolidating them
and then whenever you have a decision to
make
be okay with good enough
set the criteria you need seek out the
option that meets your criteria but
don't drive yourself crazy trying to get
and have the best option ever
you may have to lower your expectations
about your decisions not everything has
to be the best ever and you shouldn't
beat yourself up about decisions that
you make or how they turn out do the
best you can and move on
for an example of how resolving a
paradox can reveal something deeper and
more important we could think about
girdle's work this statement is not
provable
where it turns out something deeper is
going on
the assumption that it's not provable is
just false it turns out to be incredibly
complicated and very interesting
for an example of a paradox that ends up
as false
here's one that tricks a surprising
number of people it's called a
traveler's paradox
now as you'll see it must contain faulty
reasoning see if you can spot it
three weary travelers arrived at an inn
and there was a neighbor filling in for
the owner and the neighbor said i think
the room is thirty dollars and so the
travelers took out their money and paid
ten dollars each there were three of
them and they checked in and they got
settled
the neighbor wanted to make sure he had
the price right and so he checked with
the owner and he had it wrong the room
was supposed to be 25 not 30.
so he decided he would take five ones up
to the room and pay them back on the way
he said
i have five ones how am i going to
divide this up among three travelers and
so he decided he would give one of the
dollar bills to each of the travelers
and then pocket the remaining two
dollars
so now let's think about where the money
went you see each traveler paid ten
dollars and got back one that's a net of
nine dollars three times nine dollars is
27 and the neighbor kept two dollars
that's 27 plus two
that's 29
where did that last dollar go
now you can sort of see this is more of
a puzzle you know that money doesn't
disappear it's not really a paradox in
the technical sense you know the
argument here has to be faulty but for
many it's quite puzzling and it's not
very obvious where things went wrong
let's think about where the money is
you see
we added twenty seven dollars to two
dollars adding twenty seven dollars
which is what the travelers paid to the
two dollars which is what the neighbor
kept it makes no sense to add those two
numbers the two dollars that the
neighbor kept it's part of the twenty
seven dollars that they paid
they paid twenty seven dollars two of
that two of those dollars is in the
neighbor pocket the remaining three
dollars is in their pockets they got
three dollars back one each
all the money is accounted for the
thirty dollars goes like this three
dollars went back to the travelers two
dollars is in the neighbor's pocket and
twenty five dollars is with with the
owner the take-home message here is that
simple arithmetic can be tricky
in addition to space surprising things
also occur in connection to time and
einstein's theory of special relativity
picture a mechanical alarm clock
now imagine that you set the alarm clock
to go off in one hour
to anyone that's either stationary or
that is moving far less than the speed
of light relative to the clock they will
measure that an hour passes before the
alarm goes off but to someone that is
moving at a third of the speed of light
it will take an hour and four minutes
for the alarm clock to go off
at 90 percent of the speed of light it
takes two hours and 18 minutes and at
99.9 percent of the speed of light this
length of time which is only an hour in
the rest frame gets stretched to over 22
hours
almost a full day
the most famous illustration of this
kind of phenomena is an example known as
the twin paradox
so picture two identical twins
one grows up to be a banker and stays on
earth for her entire life
the other grows up to be an astronaut
and she travels at a speed of 99.9
percent of the speed of light to a
distant solar system that's located 50
light years away from us
once arriving there she quickly turns
around and returns to earth the same way
that she came again traveling at the
same speed of 99.9 of speed of light
to those of us on earth the astronauts
100 light year round trip
takes just over 100 years to complete
but time passes differently in the
astronauts moving frame of reference
as far as the astronauts concerned only
about four and a half years pass between
the start and finish of their journey
this means that the ship's clocks all
measure that four and a half years have
passed
and the astronaut only ages four and a
half years
and she only eats four and a half years
worth of food and only listens to four
and a half years of music or whatever
else she does to pass the time
but on earth 100 years of time in
history have passed
and the two twins are no longer the same
age
in what was only four and a half years
to the astronaut the astronaut sister
aged 100 years
in all likelihood everyone that the
astronaut knew before leaving on her
journey had grown old and died before
she got back home
just take a second to consider how weird
and spectacular this result really is
for all intents and purposes the
astronaut in this example has just
traveled into the future
making this an example of time travel
by moving at nearly the speed of light
the astronaut slowed down the very
passing of time in her frame of
reference
allowing her to move rapidly into the
future
the closer your speed is to the speed of
light the faster
you can move through time
in principle if you can move fast enough
you can move arbitrarily far into the
future a thousand years a million years
a billion years or more
but moving backward through time is
another thing altogether
and it's with backward time travel that
serious logical problems start to appear
the most famous illustration of these
kinds of problems is known as the
grandfather paradox let me describe it
to you
imagine that i follow a closed timeline
curve to a point in the past
at this point i encounter and then kill
my own grandfather while he's still a
child
as a consequence of these actions my
grandfather never grows up he never
meets my grandmother and he never has
any children or grandchildren
this means i'm never born
and therefore i never exist and that
means i never travel backwards through
time to kill my grandfather
so since he was never killed my
grandfather survives to meet my
grandmother and they do have children
and grandchildren together so once again
i do exist and then of course i do
travel through time to kill my
grandfather and you can see the problem
backwards time travel makes it
impossible for there to be a
self-consistent timeline
the grandfather paradox has been a
staple of science fiction since the
1930s
but in addition to producing some very
entertaining storytelling it also serves
to illustrate the logical hazards that
can come with unrestricted time travel
any system in which it's possible to
change the past suffers from these kinds
of problems and that means that any
system containing closed time-like
curves
seems to seem sure to lead to
paradoxical nonsense
to solve the paradox one must explain
why time travel could never
allow for the possibility of
self-annihilation
to do so you basically have to
reconceive the very nature of what time
travel would do
and there are two ways to do this
the first
is called branching time travel a
solution to the problem endorsed by
philosophers newell belknap and david
deutsch
the suggestion is this when you travel
back in time you do not travel to your
own
past
you travel to the past of an alternate
universe which has a past just like the
universe you left up to the moment to
which you traveled but that also
contains the event of you the time
traveler appearing at that moment
you then proceed forward in time in that
universe and deal with the consequences
of your actions there
but you can't kill your own grandfather
because your grandfather is in the past
of the universe you left you traveled to
a different universe with a different
grandfather if you kill him you will
simply prevent that universe's version
of you from being born but the event of
your birth is still safe and sound in
your original universe
this conception of time travel can quite
handily be used to make perfect sense of
many time travel stories
a second solution to the grandfather
paradox was developed by philosopher
david lewis he suggests that time travel
would not give one the ability to kill
their own grandfather because doing so
would be
impossible
essentially because you'd be predestined
not to do so
why
well think back to the block world view
of time in which the entire universe
past present and future exists as a
whole if time travel is possible the
universe already contains the events of
the time travelers traveling in time
their escapades in what we would call
both the future and the past
that means before a time traveler ever
activates their time machine
the things that they will do while in
the past have already occurred
the past is already written
so they can travel there and experience
the past they can even participate
causing things to happen in the past but
it would be impossible for them to cause
anything to happen other than what they
had already
caused
and since they clearly were born and
thus preventing their own birth is
clearly not something that they already
caused
it would be impossible for them to do so
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here